rattleballs what can you say about a
title like that rattleballs I'm not
gonna forget that time actually makes me
think of like an eighties cartoon boy it
sounds like no it sounds like a game at
like Chuckie Cheese Thank You that too
you know I'm seeing like street sharks
and biker mice from mars and stuff like
that it's like rattleballs yeah just no
no ninja rattleballs who like pizza good
that bad that was a lot of it no
robo-ninja rattleballs who liked pizza
anyway in this episode eggs okay we'll
make eggs the new pizza I like this
it'll catch on so okay so this is an
episode where Finn is once again
obsessed with not necessarily bubblegum
just like the old days of you know
serving and just doing something cuz
obviously still not over Flame Princess
so he's kind of just hanging out around
her a little too obsessively doing
everything for her so he he goes away
and he's in this junkyard where he comes
across
rattleballs who is a upside down gumball
machine and it used to be one of the
guards for Princess Bubblegum but they
were too good at what they did so they
almost got two strikes it for him he got
free will and has become not a pacifist
but not as violent and he's the ultimate
sword master at least he's really good
at it and teaches fit all sorts of sword
stuff for it or at least puts him
through some things and then throws eggs
em cuz I mean did you notice there's
really no teaching involved even when
he's like you know he's like yeah you
will master the ultimate form of you
know whatever that shadowing or whatever
that was and like you just disappear and
make things explode and he's just like
now you try it's like you didn't teach
them anything and Finn just goes oh oh
oh he's like do that every day for 10
years and have a robot body and you help
be just like me umm so then it goes bad
to bubblegum uh pretty much tells her
about him because he swears an oath to
her she calls tried to destroy him see
say he's not dangerous anymore so
pretends to destroy him and lets them
both pretty much still serve her and
yeah I'm just talking about the biggest
scene uh I'm for it they really have you
for a split second I thought like she
really freaking killed him at the end I
was just like holy cuz we saw her
trying to do that before with that one
guy when there was stuck in the ditch
and they send him out James that's right
send James out and all the names that's
the one I remember kind of like all the
weird kooky maids I remember James cuz
it's not a kooky name maybe and dreams
in the Giant Peach know our friend James
know James Baxter remember that was
Baxter's me that's why I remember it
because I thought he was back and he
wasn't um I want him back bring him back
no don't it won't be as good so ya know
it's uh I love the design of this thing
of this this gumball this upside-down
gumball machine cuz it took me a second
to even realize what he was I mean I
recognized her the Gumbel's at the Bob
I'm like what uh we're designed with the
arms I mostly read a little bit read I'm
like oh it's upset yeah so I was pretty
dumb on that one um but just that one
just that one not anything else in the
show at all I'm amazing
and ya know it was definitely a fun
emphasis guy I liked how just kind of
bizarre he is and everything served like
it can you know you think it's going one
directional throw it another way you
know like it is a very long story which
I will tell you right now and it goes
into it
his obsession with throwing eggs is
hilarious and like I said I just love
how he like really never taught him
anything you know he started putting
through these obstacles but he never
told him what to learn so yeah and I
like the compromise ending um I'm still
not wondering where they're going
finn and you know the girlfriend area
because at first i was kind of like oh
my god are we gonna do this again you
know trying to get back with peoples and
stuff but they don't you know they they
make it more like you know he's probably
trying to think of like the good old
days and like just his work and stuff
and he's like well that's something and
I used to like her as me though I don't
replace it a little bit even if he's not
aware of it you know that's probably
ways doing so well by this obsession in
the grave and the graveyard in the
junkyard
hey people's yeah that's true yeah just
like you know trying to protect her and
stuff and although I guess you could
yeah and getting the three weeks for
Miller
what do you milk a minx was that yes um
which was a great cut cuz it's like well
first of all it's great weights like you
know you know when she says I'm out of
milk he's gonna say I'm gonna get you
milk I love him running like this yeah
the whole time uh but then the cut to
three weeks later I mean that's just a
great that's a great editor you know
he's gonna have like this cookie story
when he comes back and I I love how the
milk is boiling like that big two is not
even much metal but no I did I thought
it was fun I thought I was definitely I
think that's a cool character I love for
him to come back a bit he's funny it's a
it's a fun design and ya know I thought
was definitely I won you don't talk
about the tragedy of the rattleballs in
general just all of them getting give I
didn't tear race being destroyed in a
matter of seconds you know I kind of
genocide means nothing anymore
it's horrible say I've gotten used to it
when it comes to people's honestly yeah
it's just other things are it sort of
like I mean like I said on the one hand
it's like god it's so cold and dark and
calculating stuff on the other hand it's
like it at least it's a very definite
character like I said before she was
just sort of generally nice and now it's
like when I see her I mean it's like I
don't see you like just someone who's
hahaha just whatever I really Kingdom
teehee it's like she looks like she just
always has the weight of the world on
shoulders and she has to make like these
really tough choices so if you have to
like sort of shut off her humanity
sometimes you know and they kind of
shown you why as well so a lot of these
choices where you like do that is harsh
what's wrong with you it sort of shows
why in other episodes as well so even
though you don't know all the details
like you know how when did she start
making the people what's even her grand
purpose or whatever is it just to
repopulate or whatever so yeah but at
the same time you do get the idea that
it's like yeah she does have like this
incredible weight on her all the time so
I've kind of gotten used to she's got to
make this really tough dark tragic
choice in a matter of a second yeah
aside a lot of what people forget is at
least with this one and as much as
depends on how you want to see
rattleballs and never robots they
weren't candy people they were robots so
how human or alive are they well I mean
that's it's a question that can easily
come up and there could be huge debates
over tor whatever because people are
weird that way bringing it up but what
I'm saying is is that for me seeing the
whole destruction of the rattleballs and
all that it was kind of like okay
they're robots they did their purpose
they were too good at it they needed to
be taken out well by me you obviously
see like I need him in particular like
he formed a personality you know it's
the short circuit thing you know yeah I
exact I don't know where he forms of
personality which I'm always served like
like I'm really on board for these ideas
of like what's living what's not and you
know how much artificial intelligence
can lead to something living and stuff
but I always have an issue when it's
just like just and then life happens
yeah no let's let's do this right you
know take like the memory of a person
somehow and I put it on disk and put
that disk in a robot it's like wait a
minute that's the memories of a real
person but the person is dead well I
mean it's like something really
conflicting like that not just boom life
you know they kind of I see I guess you
can say they were already building up to
it with them I had loved having them
outside of this club almost like a Fight
Club if you rest
ring where there's the one guy who's
head in half would look up you know
looking for a changing I mean I already
kind of shows it they had a personality
outside of just the robotic ways but
then right after that they are back to
the robotic ways yeah number ones go up
there number two stay down here don't do
you know um do I think she was cruel no
not really um she did what was she did
what was best for the entire kingdom
could she have reprogrammed him Posse Oh
what's if they would follow her to like
you know all the ones go over there all
the twos go over there and be crushed
why couldn't she just say stop being
violent go grow flowers or something
good question that's actually a good
question what the hell Peebles what the
hell that is the one thing about her
character too and I don't necessarily
like the character Mike yes as it is
probably the writing is that there is
the same thing with the James one where
it's like she sabotaged all the plans in
order to get this other plan to happen
I'm like I don't know it's like the you
know the Devils in the details there
it's like you know come on you don't
have to do this there's there's other
ways around this you know but I mean I
know the idea they're trying to get
across and they're trying to emphasize
so it's like I respect that but it's
always like you know but but wait a
minute there's about 20 other ways this
for half of this so well I also think
with this one they were trying to show
what Finn was following you know her a
hundred percent well that yeah that's
why I was when I was worried if he was
gonna see him as like a cautionary tale
yeah like that buddy he doesn't seem to
I mean they're both they're hitting
their hands on the table now and stuff I
mean so or maybe it's leading to
something I don't know I well I took it
as kind of him being like okay you could
do it a hundred percent but at the same
time don't let it rule you but does he
see that I don't know I'm I guess I'm
hoping he did yeah it was a definite
yeah that that's where I thought they
were going but then we see them both
kind of doing that you know I don't know
it didn't seem like he you know nothing
sir yes I'm in there so there's so I
don't know um I I still like it I think
a lot of things with this show like I
said it's it's probably not a show where
you should focus on the details really
I'm even though they have all these
little nice touches and continuity and
stuff it's like there's a million times
Jay could have turned into whatever and
gotten Howard I mean there's like a lot
of the characters powers are like you
know come on I think could have done
this they could have done that um but I
I don't think that's the focus of the
show you know I think it's more of the
broad ideas and stuff but um but they
still drive me nuts I think by the way
the whole training montage I think it
was mocking most montages hmm where it's
you know there he's doing all of this
stuff and it was one day look at most
movies where he had training montages
that supposedly take place over like a
weekend like rocky is training for a
boxing match that's like two weeks away
and somehow in two weeks he becomes
super-strong it's super and like full of
endurance enough it's one of those kind
of things like now that's kind of
yeah like yeah like I think
South Park did that too it's like you
know what we need is a sports montage I
just you know don't you know you just
put a bunch of images and music and
suddenly you're ready you know it takes
like five minutes you know and that's
kind of what it is you know and I think
that's what this was we're gonna have
him doing these absurdly stupid things
that for some reason would somehow teach
him but we're not going to give any
explanation why well I see like rewatch
the rocky montages what are they're
doing they're running they're boxing
things but they're not saying what is
this actually doing okay him doing this
yeah it's - what strengthen your arm
give you what more dexterity when you
punch what exactly that's something I
liked a little bit in uh I kinda like
the Million Dollar Baby is that they you
know you did see him actually teach
again oh no when you hit the bag get to
do like this this gives more force here
you know the knuckles here that's gonna
make it harder in that you know it's
like he's actually showing you know the
strategy behind but yeah
and the Rocky movies is like harder I
think you were supposed to hit with your
knuckles Ohio I'm pulling on my ass I
can't remember what with the flat of
your hand I pulled that out by ass I
have no idea what he said I just know he
said something I never saw it uh $100
baby I think I've read up too soon it's
always sunny in philadelphia that's a
great that is a great show by the way
you check it in the montage that's what
I kind of took it as it was poking fun
at all the other training montages out
there and then he's just like oh yeah
you know you'll be this way if you keep
doing this every day for ten years and
get a robot it's like yeah that's kind
of what it is yeah and what I like is
that like I said I don't think he's
actually gotten anything out of that oh
yeah didn't appear better he didn't
teach him a thing
what about now again okay yeah which I
find really funny though considering
last episode he was just like I'm
usually Austin Nelson he's kind of like
yeah well I think it's probably one of
those things like compared to Tim you
know Rumble balls anyway is called oh my
god you already forgot I remember James
I remember James Robredo balls balls I
something with an R that has two
syllables followed by balls okay like
two minutes ago
well I remember James that's what's most
important Rumble balls so a final
thought it's about you know ramping
balls
let's hit now it's not funny cuz now
you're just you know coming up with this
stuff just to you know be funny
well Rumble balls you were just you know
unless it Wally are my plan to make it
look like I made up Rumble to it you're
anti-mass i no idea what the strategy
million dollar baby was either and you
didn't like okay didn't like she liked
it beaten up or something but
hugs and then that's Karate Kid Oh
wasn't she beaten up and cried
that's the neck Karate Kid Karate Kid
part 4 yeah no there is yeah it's awful
so it's part three oh wait so it's part
two oh wait so is part one except for
his Halloween costume that wasn't
awesome okay it's costume I like the
first note by the way go go after him
what what's so good about Karate Kid oh
he's gone sweet no I can still see your
butt move it that's a bit better I guess
rubber ball